the white house is now asking congress
to provide green cards to tens of
thousands of afghan refugees so that
they can stay in the country
indefinitely joe biden's also demanding
that lawmakers provide more than six
billion dollars to help resettle afghan
refugees on u.s military bases
according to the wall street journal the
money would also provide quote
resettlement benefits to afghans
stephen miller is a former senior white
house advisor
he joins us to assess stephen i'm
i remember back in the day when afghan
veterans
died waiting in line for health care at
obama biden's va hospitals and then
obama biden bureaucrats paid them
bonuses to cover up these wait lists now
they're bringing in afghans giving them
green cards health care
probably free college tuition food
stamps
that doesn't make a lot of sense does it
well president trump used to say
that under president obama
illegal aliens were treated better than
our veterans which of course is true
today under president biden we can now
add to that that under president biden
unvetted unverified unauthorized afghan
nationals are also treated better than
our veterans let me briefly break down
for your audience what is in the
proposal now the body administration is
relying on the fact that many in the
media either won't understand or won't
care to explain
in their newspapers or their other
outlets
what is actually in the proposal and you
have summarized it exactly and correctly
it provides
free lifetime welfare to all afghan
nationals that biden has flown into the
united states to date or that he may
choose to fly here at any point over the
next 13 months and we can assume that if
that were to be included in the upcoming
government funding bill it would just be
continually extended every year
thereafter but that's only just part of
it it keeps going
they redefine afghan national to mean
anybody who has ever lived for a length
of time in afghanistan even if they're
not living there now and haven't lived
there in many many years so in other
words it allows joe biden to go to say
for example pakistan filled planes up
with afghan nationals who've been living
in pakistan for decades fly them in the
united states and give them lifetime
welfare it also gives them as you
correctly mentioned green cards what's a
green card permanent residency and a
path to voting citizenship you know what
else comes with that chain migration
so if you bring in say a hundred
thousand people they can then bring in
five hundred thousand people and that's
not all they also include a catch-all
waiver get ready for this a catch-all
waiver that allows majorcas to
waive the statutory in other words the
legal entry bars on people who are
guilty of trafficking who are guilty of
human and sex trafficking who are guilty
of drug crimes who are guilty of a wide
variety of criminal offenses or who
present a public health threat so in
other words on the same day
that you are being ordered to surrender
to all of these government mandates all
health mandates are waivable for you
guessed it afghan nationalism
that is a summary of the proposal let me
get this straight so if you're an opium
trafficker
or you're a dude that has a child bride
and toe that
because remember
only seven percent of these people we
brought over were actually helping us
the rest of these people were not they
just got to the plane fast enough or the
taliban let them through and then said
you'd take them
exactly joe biden's immigration policy
was literally outsourced to the taliban
do you think that would have happened
under donald trump i don't think so
the taliban is choosing now who gets to
be an american citizen
this project jesse will not end well
well i don't trust biden to vet these
people he couldn't even vet his vp
look what happened to her that's exactly
right stephen miller thank you or his
atf nominee or anyone else for that
matter or anybody right
thanks so much stop the bill
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else